I'm here to brief you on the details of
an officer-involved shooting that took
place overnight
I'm sorry to report that one of our
officers was killed in the line of duty
this morning
here are the preliminary details as we
know them
this morning around 1am dispatch
received a call of a domestic
disturbance in the 800 block of East
Flamingo Road
arriving officers made contact with the
suspect vehicle near University Center
and Flamingo
the suspect was armed with a firearm and
fired at our officers both responding
officers discharged their Duty weapons
one officer was struck and critically
critically wounded
one civilian was also struck both were
transported to local hospitals the
suspect 24 year old Tyson Hampton
fled the area and was taken into custody
later by officers with assistance of a
K-9 unit near the area of Desert Inn and
Eastern
Hampton refused to comply with officer's
commands when he got out of the vehicle
and this is when K-9 was released
he was subsequently taken into custody
and received minor injuries
during that phase of the of
rest
our officer who was killed in the line
of duty is Officer Trung Tai
spelling
t-r-u-o-n-g last name spelled t-h-a-i
he was 49 years old and has worked with
lvmpd since 1999.
he was currently assigned to both or two
South Central Airy command
officer Ty suffered a gunshot wound to
his torso
I was at the hospital early this morning
with his ex-wife and his daughter
our condolences go out to his family
and we will be helping them in any way
we can in the following days
the incident demonstrates the dangers
our officers face every day
just putting on the uniform and doing
their job
during difficult times like this we
appreciate our partnership with the
community who always show their support
to our fallen officers and their
families
further details will be provided later
as per protocol
with our 72-hour ois briefing
and I'll take any questions you may have
at this time
he died at Sunrise Hospital
sure from Bardo this is the ninth ois if
I'm not mistaken this year last year
there were five ois's reported is there
concern that this is something becoming
more common obviously for your
department this this is a
business yeah anytime there's an ois
it's a concern as as you are very wealth
uh aware that we just recently had ois
involving North Las Vegas and one in
Henderson so um yes it's a concerning
and hopefully that's it's not a trend or
it is a you know you know what I don't
want to surmise I don't want to make the
judgments on that but we are seeing an
increase in violence Associated against
our officers on a daily basis
it had to do with
I'm sorry
no not yet
we do know but I'm not going to release
them now
we are aware of some previous arrests
and those that information will be
provided at the 72-hour brief
s
correct
you answered your question
no I I don't mean to be facetious but
you're you're exactly right it is in
close proximity and it is an area that
we have been paying attention to
and here recently and and we're going to
ensure that we put all hands on deck to
ensure that we provide safety in that
community area
no I I wish to uh um you know he's he's
a he's an honorable officer a
commendable officer he's done a
fantastic job as part of the law
enforcement Community through his his
tenure here on 22-23 years
and um
we'll provide further information on his
career once the family has been had time
to mourn and assimilate associated with
his death
all right thank you very much I
appreciate your time